Freedom Unity
equality
how did the European flag come to
represent these ideals
the Council of Europe and later the
European communities adopted a flag
12 gold stars on a blue background
since then it's become a symbol of
European values a symbol of peace and
hope that emerged From the Ashes of
World War II
it represents Unity solidarity and
Harmony among the peoples of Europe
[Music]
today the flag has also become a
powerful emblem Beyond EU borders a
rallying point for people fighting for
their rights for freedom and democracy
dignity and equality the rule of law and
human rights peace and security
nearly 70 years after it was created the
EU flag does not only represent European
ideals but it has become a symbol of
Hope
thank you